well I'm glad you mentioned Hillary
because I think the audience knows one
of my guilty pleasures is reading the
tabloids and this week 25 things you
don't know about me on that to say I was
tickled and delighted this mr. cover of
Us Weekly is an understatement and it
you know I mean I was in this once 25
things you don't know about me I there's
mine yes yeah see okay so like Hillary
some of the things I love to snack on
Hot Chili Peppers and I put hot sauce on
everything that was a actual controversy
last week but she actually does Bill
Clinton proposed to me twice before I
said yes the first time is about a
threesome
but when I was a girl I wrote to NASA to
ask if I could become an astronaut they
wrote a very polite letter back saying
they didn't take girls they're gonna
regret that in about a year I am and
always will be a Beatles fan I also
really love Adele isn't trying to get
the Millennials okay but you know we
have something called equal time in
America so now the other candidates are
getting their 25 things you don't know
about
ten versus coming out next week here ice
em up ted cruz's 25 things you know
about me I spent my entire freshman year
of high school stuffed in a locker
as a child I used to imagine what it
must be like to have an imaginary my
nickname at Princeton was this
my favorite Beatle is whoever your
favorite Beatle is if it would help you
like me mirrors don't show my reflection
I named the stick up my ass Hey
caravan take-take-take ii take some of
your heart medication structure why
what'd you hear
my Cuban half once robbed my Canadian
half at night for him my children love
to play hide and seek sometimes for
weeks that it's tired Jesus once
descended from heaven just to punch me
in the face and of course I smell with
my tongue